今日は外れそうです皆さん最近欲しいみ
ましたこちら見たいんですよ僕綺麗な
欲しいプラネタリウムとかゆの近くにない
しなるほなんかこういうでこういう双眼鏡
と思ってないんで外舘ても夜寒いんじゃ
ないですかどうやったら星が見えるかなと
思った時にこちら暗く c ライトして
ないようスタープロジェクターというもの
がいますもまさにまさにもう年代を置いて
パちゃったらもうの部屋重要でほしい
だらけになるみたいなやつです猫シェイプ
0かなりとこれを使えば部屋なく星が
見れるんじゃないかと思いました買ってみ
ましたあけてみましょう
小さいなんてこんな小さいのファンでも何
かわかりやすそうですね usb ケーブル
何に使うねっうわっ北海同じは大きな
ペルーを入れて正解だな
これでいいのでこれでいいので ok これ
でもいいらしいですペアターボベンチに
出ればいいんじゃねやったなぁ簡単な音が
欲しい見る訳だからなかっ昔っからとか
思ったんですけど思ってる簡単豆腐ねで子
さんも入れて勉強吸収房
つけまーす水2
んあっだって伝わるかなぁなんか2種類
ありますねこれはパリぴモードですねパレ
日ボードと普通ですけどすげーこれはカル
カド打たなきゃねー力とばかりずれたん
です2ミニパティモードにしてみますか
ある日モードああああっああ
これはパリ日ですね漸増がも激しすぎるの
なんの
えっ
はいはいてあげるつとありますでしょうか
これプラネタリウムか多分これねーパリ p
ロードじゃないこの普通にキレイなんです
よねゆな月もいいからこういう感じで部屋
中が星空ンっているわけでございます
ラインここで僕思ったんですけど若干弱い
なって思ったんですよね光が会がうっすら
と白くホストがちょっとキラキラしてる
くらいだあったのでこれもっともーっ
た沢山の星は壁図2個付けまくったら
めちゃくちゃロマンチックなんじゃないか
と思いまして今回この大津を
プロジェクターたくさん準備しました
2にたくさんのプロジェクターがあれば
良い幻想的で美しい変になるんじゃないか
と思いまして今日はとても綺麗な動画です
よ皆さん西湖でスシローダンチェッカー細
0見せてあげると思います手が着けてい
ます
ですできましたこの部屋はさぞ
南天の葉しづらかったりでしょ置き方を
工夫せなきゃねちゃんとおかないと多分
非礼な星にはなんないんでもうちょっと
綺麗な栄養を書く感じでセットしていきま
しょーかいてあげて早速全てに英智して
いきましょうまずはパリ p ボードでは
なく普通にあの綺麗な光の方でやってい
ますぜっちおん本をボンボンボン夫婦ただ
まだわからないでいいですねもうすでに
ちょっとし彼を感じるんですけどもヘアー
比べたらこの部屋はどうなのでしょうか図
ああ
本
大
うーん何が綺麗ですね綺麗だけど持っ何か
欲しいじゃないんだよね顔も比例な
ちょっとグループ部屋を見回してみました
[音楽]
するのは
ん
たないんだえっ顔怖パイ時で上から見ると
こんな感じですジャッカーんからいい
くらいなんですよね実際いやでも綺麗なら
なんかすごいいい壁がね散り散りに光っ
てる感じではありますね
まあまあですね大事なのはここから次は
もう前パリぴモードヘアきたらせるみ
ましょうこっちが本番ですよこのはずの光
言われてたのかリピモード待ったなしって
ことなんで不不不不不不不不不不不不不を
止めます
応募んっええええええええでは雑草でパリ
ぷモーゼ部屋を光らせてみましょう1ああ
俺がするんだけどさいきます
ぽい
いいした
car
ああ良い
ビスコじゃねーかっ
[音楽]
me
memecar
car
me
あった